you know it's also a thing now is
hashtag black boys dance too this comes
from Huffington Post black boys dance to
was a campaign an all-male dance company
aiming to examine blackness manhood and
justice through dance with an
understanding that in a world where
black stillness is preferred because
that's how I prefer my blacks still
apparently is I guess I'm gonna try to
say that we want blacks to be dead is
that the idea I think just just do not
aggressive
anyway they make a leap see Elliot like
leap to all things dynamic bigger fluid
a revolutionary so the motivation for
the founding company came from the
belief based on experience that his
industry lacked adequate representation
for black pen because when I think of an
industry where black men can't get a
fair shake I think of dance
screw you Channing Tatum and really just
hearing Tatum everyone else in step up
hashtag black people can play basketball
too by the way I first it seemed absurd
but then we realize or think of
contemporary dance and this is more I
guess sort of a it's it's a mix of sort
of merging class with contemporary and I
can actually just an where they're
coming from considering last year's
formally no obvious is Kramer from
Seinfeld Michael Richards Nutcracker
debacle
[Music]
I have never heard how could you not
hurt you never heard no cheese wheel is
banned from cart living under a rock
apparently there's no question of it
would that joke plate today you know did
you like this video it what you didn't
oh you're a cat person well that makes
sense
disregard him and or her see everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video you know what crazy cat you
can get back you can you can comment
below too as to why you don't like it